So welcome back to the C.G. Jung Helpdesk and today's very special topic, which is a movie analysis about the movie Scarface from the '80s. Al Pacino as Tony Montana. The scriptwriter is Oliver Stone and the director is Brian De Palma.
So all heavyweights in Hollywood, and this is a very famous movie and a very culturally impactful movie.
And yeah, there's specific reasons I want to talk about it because as always, I see there really interesting psychological things happening that will help us understand some key concepts about Jungian psychology.
And yeah, this is Why I chose the movie, because of this proclivity of man to get obsessed and also possessed and their behavior and their actions and the things that they're doing, especially in the world and worldly things. And Jung says this has a very specific reason, and this is because of their anima.
So their female side in their psyche. That is acting in, let's say, independent ways that it takes a man to do certain things and take certain actions that influences their life greatly. And they can be very conscious of that or can be very unconscious.
And the effect of the anima, of this feminine side that the man tries to get into, basically what men are doing. All human beings are doing is influenced by their psyche and the unconscious things that are acting in their psyche.
And Jung sees there really personification of, say, certain, let's say, psychologies or functions or forces. And he says there are masculine force and a feminine force acting in with each, each of us.
But he says in man, As they have a predominantly masculine psychology, the feminine side is quite on the unconscious and independent side. And this he calls anima. And yeah, the anima is very worldly. It's very earthly. And the interesting effect is the things that the anima touches, they become magical.
So they have a special draw for man to say like, oh, I need to pursue this. I need to possess it. I need to get at that. And he sees there a lot of drive that men have coming from that, trying to fill their own psychology, but projecting it out in the world and trying to find something that they need inside in the outside.
So what happens then? Men are prone to lose themselves in the world. In worldly things and things that are happening in the bodily, physical plane of our existence and material things.
So Scarface is a story of such a man who is completely possessed by his anima and him learning during the course of the movie that he's actually lost his humanity and his soul through his actions and his complete entanglement in the story.
So, and there's not now a quote from Carl Gustav Jung, but rather a quote from Tony Montana, which happens during this incredibly great and influential scene in the restaurant. So a lot of quotes that Scarface the movie is famous for happen in this restaurant.
And I don't curse often in this program, but In this case, I will be because it's hard to cite Tony Montana without cursing. And he's saying to his friend Manny, who's there, and he's sitting there with his wife Elvira, so Tony's wife, is this it? That's what's it all about, Manny?
Eating, drinking, fucking, sucking, snorting, then what? You're 50. You got a bag for a belly. You got tits, You need a bra. They got hair on them. You got a liver, they got spots on it. And you're eating this fucking shit. Looking like these rich fucking mummies in here. Look at that. A junkie. A fucking junkie for a wife. She don't eat nothing.
I can't even have a kid with her, Manny. Her womb is so polluted, I can't even have a fucking little baby with her.
So this is the realization of Tony after all of the successes with all his achievements, that there is something empty inside of him, that he is, has lost something, that this is a culmination of his pursuit of the things that the anima brought him towards and he let himself be brought to by the anima and his incomplete psyche.
So we take a look at Tony and how Tony is as a character. Tony is an immigrant. From Cuba, being persecuted there. He fought communists and was imprisoned and there became an assassin, which is like his fate, the fate of his life story that he has to kill.
And the whole movie is about that, that he has to progress by killing people up to the point where he kills the wrong people or lets not the right people be killed. And has to pay his own life with that. So he's saying, I always tell the truth, even when I lie. He's completely unfiltered. He just says what he wants. He takes what he wants.
He forces people to do what he wants, and he has no holding back. He's personifying in a sense the American dream. So coming with nothing to America and becoming incredibly successful, incredibly rich. Of course, through illegal means, but he's pushing for that in every single interaction he's in. He always pushes for more. He always pushes for higher.
He's never really satisfied. He never has any joy. This is not only when he's at the top, but even when he's going up, there is no joy for him. There's always more to get. And he says that integrity is a key part of his being by saying, all I have in this world is my balls. And my word, and I'd break them for no one.
He is incredibly driven. He has a weak background and he's pushing, pushing, pushing boldly in any situation. And a lot of people push against him and he's always pushing back harder. But in his heart, he's a, he's a family man. So he's taking care of his sister. He wants to start a family. He wants to have children.
Which is a kind of a contrast what he's doing and pursuing there. But he seems to be focused on, or have this ideal of a more traditional lifestyle and marriage and family.
So what is typical for these kind of movies, like American dream movies, And you have a lot of them that are structured like this. It's this rise and fall narrative. So that means somebody is starting from nothing, he's working his way up, reaches the top, and then falls down. So a lot of movies work like this.
A lot of Leonardo DiCaprio movies are working like this, where he's playing The Wolf of Wall Street or where he's like The Aviator and even Something like The Great Gatsby, it's always getting more, more, more up to the point where it just tilts down. So these movies are great to see, they're fun to see, and there's a very specific reason for that.
Because on the one side, we want to see people rise through the ranks and fight their way to the top, but also we want to see them fall. Maybe this is a kind of American thing because these movies tend to come out of America.
But yeah, this rise part of Tony and of this story is very similar to how Jung sees life evolving and how he sees that people are living their life.
So when we come into this world as children, we are completely unconscious, completely unaware of ourselves, cannot really do something, cannot act for ourself. And we are dissolved in this family psychology. Jung even calls children this appendix of the psychology of the mother.
So first, the child is the, like an appendix, uh, to the body of the mother. But even when the child leaves the body of the mother, psychologically is still entangled and identical with the mother. It takes time to get outside of that and establish themselves as a person.
And this then has to happen for the psychology of the, of the family or the surroundings.
And Jung saw there really the great value of Freudian psychology and the things that Freud was trying to do with his patients to bring them out in the world and to do and to act and to establish themselves, which means build a career, build reputation, get a family, have a job, all these different things.
So getting out of the family psychology and looking for these things in the external world. And like the sun rising through the day and moving through the day, it's rising, rising, rising till noon where it reaches the top.
And this is what this quote is here saying, that as a rule, the life of a young person is characterized by general expansion and striving towards concrete ends. So he sees their life very collective. So people look into society and they try for these goals. People are there not necessarily very unique.
There's not very unique things in saying, okay, I want to get an education and I want to have a career and I want to be in a relationship. This is all kind of collective goals that people are striving towards, which is not a bad thing. This is a very good thing to come up in a society, to contribute to society. And yeah, doing this in a good and efficient manner.
Well, Tony does it in a very criminal manner, but he has success. Like, his success speaks for itself. And what is driving Tony there extremely strong and what can be seen as in his behavior is the function of the anima. There's another quote for that: An anima can bring about the most amazing results.
She can send a man practically anywhere in the world. What a real woman could not do, the anima can do. If the anima says so, one must go. And this is the reason why Tony came to America because he saw those American movies and he saw what is possible in America. He saw this desire.
So he took this journey by boat from Cuba to Florida to start at the absolute bottom as a refugee in a refugee camp, but saying, okay, I will make it. I will get out of here. And the whole movie and the first half of the movie is just him seeing things and wanting them.
Like he sees money, he sees drugs, he also sees women, and he especially sees Elvira, the wife of his boss at the time, and says, okay, I want to have her. I need her. I need all these things. And he pushes for more and more and more. In every deal, he tries to get a better deal.
He tries to get like more responsibility, more the difficult thing. And he completely goes over people to establish himself. And he does so boldly. He does this openly and he does it with a lot of violence. So getting out of this refugee camp, it is because he kills someone.
The first drug deal he does, he has to kill someone and he steals their money. And he has to usurp Frank, his boss, and he does that by killing him, or let Manny kill him. So all these things, Jung would say, this is nothing that really can come out of a society, right? Or even like a partner to demand those things.
But he says there's a psychological need happening there in people that causes them to do these really extreme things. He says, in our consciousness, we have willpower. We can do certain things. But for some people, willpower is already exceeded when they need to wait 15 minutes or 30 minutes, or they have to pay attention for an hour at a meeting or whatever.
But there are these kind of people who have seemingly boundless energy, who are just incredibly driven. And he says those people, it's not really their own psychology or their own individuality or their consciousness being there in the driver's seat.
He says there is something in the background that pushes themselves on these persons that they have to act, that they have to do these things. And it is highly, highly impersonal. Similar with an emotion, when someone is angry, this is not necessarily a choice. And people can be blind of rage and do horrible, horrible things in rage.
And this is then not a choice. Jung says we have these unconscious forces in us that can influence our lives and influence our behavior, and we can, might regret them afterwards because only then we are out of this circle of influence. Then the emotion is gone and we suddenly realize all the things we have done.
And he says they're a very strong force to contend with, is the anima. It's this feminine side. It's similar for women, he says.
For them, it's the animus, so it's a masculine psychology, or the things that he describes as masculine psychology, acting on them and also bringing them to do things that might be regrettable and very impersonal, how they then live their life and experience their life. So yeah, if the anima says so, one must go.
And that brings us to the midpoint shift in multiple ways. One is of course the story of Tony Montana, where his story starts to shift, but also in a movie, this is a very typical thing that happens that you have in the middle of the movie, an event happening that changes the whole dynamics of the movie and basically launches a new movie.
For example, in Jaws, it's a moment when they actually go onto the water to kill the shark. And Brody says, yes, I have to kill the shark. And The Matrix is when Neo is told that he's not the one.
And in Scarface, it is when he gets his success, when he has reached the pinnacle, he has everything, he has houses, he has Elvira, he has married her, but at the same time, it all feels very much empty. And Jung describes this point also in life. So Jung talks about this.
Midpoint shift in life that we would today call a midlife crisis. But Jung did not have these words yet, but he describes this exact thing, and he describes this in this quote: What youth found and must find outside, the man of life's afternoon must find within himself.
Which means there's a psychological shift happening in our lives. As soon as we hit end of 30, 40, so at the midpoint of life, that these psychological needs and the orientation we should have turns from outward more to inward. So the sun is at its highest point, but it's slowly moving down.
It's already preparing for the sunset and for the disappearance. So Jung also says the second part of life is this kind of preparation for death.
And while you said the first part of life is very well managed with Freudian psychology to say that people need to go out, establish themselves in society, take over the rules of society, contribute to society, it changes and they turn psychologically after the midpoint shift.
And this is where Jung started because he realized that The patients he had over 40, Freudian psychology would not work because it doesn't make sense to tell these people go outside because they went outside and they achieved those things.
So he says people rather need to turn inward and they need to realize that there are these psychological realities and there has to be kind of reflection on life of the things that happened before. And there's another quote for that where he says, Life begins with 40. Everything before that is field research. This is where he says culture is happening.
When people have then the experience of having done things, achieved things, and turning inward to realize what is happening inside of them and realizing that there were forces inside of them that were pushing them into certain directions. And to describe the situation that Tony finds himself in, in the midpoint of his story.
There's this other quote from a seminar. So Dr. Jung says, what happens in the moment of a great achievement? And a student there, Miss Taylor, says, inflation. Dr. Jung continues, that is a usual thing, for in a moment of great achievement you cannot help admiring yourself.
You think you You are such a hell of a fellow that you stumble over yourself and down you come with a crash. So the hardest thing to stand is not suffering, but success. That is the worst thing that can happen to you. Success usually creates a really dangerous inflation. So this is what's happening with, with Tony.
He's being driven, but at the same time, it's not really himself that is driving him. And he confuses that. He confuses his ambition with himself, and Jung calls this effect of inflation. So really an inflated ego, like a balloon being blown up with force that do not actually belong to it.
So this causes people to act in these grandiose things, these really exaggerated things, to think of themselves as invincible and to be of great importance, and that they force themselves onto other people. Force them to do things.
And this, of course, with inflation has to become, has to come deflation and this crash that Jung talks about, which is the fall of the rise and fall. And Jung says, a criminal shows by his crime his will to destroy himself. He has committed murder, so he will be judged and his head will be cut off. And that is what he wanted.
Moreover, when a person murders, he has murdered himself morally, which is of course just as bad as real death. And second, the thief whom the police do not catch has nonetheless robbed himself, and the murderer is his own executioner. So what, what Tony is struggling with is not really a bad conscience.
He does not feel bad about the things he has done because he saw them as necessary and the right thing to do. But at the same time, he feels the emptiness of this all, that— this is the quote from the movie I started with— that there has to be more than that, that this cannot be enough, and that this is not a whole life. And this is what the second part of the movie is about.
So he is marrying Elvira, this woman he wanted to have, even though he knew nothing about her. But the real love happening there is between Manny, which is his best friend, and Gina, which is his sister. And they fall in love and they want to start a family and get married and all these things.
So these are the things that Tony kind of wants, but he cannot really find because he's looking at the completely wrong places and the wrong directions.
This is why you have this incredibly strong scene at the end of the movie where, uh, he tries to find Gina because she has run away and he cannot find Manny and cannot make the connection that those two might be running away together.
And he goes to the house and he realizes that Manny and his sister are together and they're super happy to see him, but he kind of blacks out and kills Manny. And this is an impulse reaction, and this is what kills his humanity. And you can really, really see it in his face.
This is an amazing scene that he knows he's done for because he kills Manny, he kills his best friend, and basically estranges his sister completely by killing him. So he loses this part of humanity, like the last access he had to normal people.
He loses at that point and he's completely then apathetic in the end and just has his last standoff and die. But he's clear that he's gone. There's his soul is gone. His redemption is gone. And there's nothing now he can do to prevent this violent end that he already seeded for himself in the beginning.
So we have to look really into his closest circle of people he surrounds himself with to understand his psychology better. And this is very typical. Jung says the people we are attracted to and we keep ourselves around, they tell us something about ourselves. So there is a reaction happening between two people when they interact and intermingle.
The people you are attracted to, or even not attracted to, strongly not attracted to, tell you something about yourself. He says this is a kind of psychological need that needs to be not filled, but it's more of, of a finding of a missing part that you can find in another person or think you might find there.
So for example, this is in the external world, but also internally when we dream and in our dreams we meet other persons, those are not separate persons. Those are separate parts of our psychology. That we can interact with and that are kind of split off, that have their own way, their own worldview.
And as stories symbolize also this artistic cultural ways, which are similar to dreams, we can look at these persons and say, okay, what does it tell us about Tony and the headspace that he fills? Like what psychological functions of Tony are being externalized and dramatized? In the story.
And a big part of that is, of course, Elvira, which is this complete externalization and symbolization of Tony's desire to get things and achieve things. Between them is absolutely no chemistry. Like, Elvira is completely apathetic. She's just sleeping all day, taking drugs.
She's kind of, yeah, also unfiltered like Tony, but he sees not that person there. He only sees the things that she symbolizes, and she symbolizes beauty and achievement and all these different things. And this is, by the way, the only woman that Tony is really interested in and pursues in the movie.
So while Manny is going off and meeting many different women, like in every scene it's another woman. Tony has only eyes for Elvira and at the same time tries to make a family happen with her, even though that she really, really does not like him and does not want to be around him. But still, she's there. She's also as empty as him.
So they're kind of fitting in their worldview and in their actions. So She is kind of devoid of personality and there is no future with her.
So he wants to have a family, she can't have children, and that puts Tony really into a kind of bind that she externalizes what he, or symbolizes what he else tries to do with his life. Achieve something, but then realize, okay, there's no future in there. This is completely empty. And this is what the scene in the restaurant is about.
And from the beginning of the movie around is Manny, who's also a fellow refugee, who acts as a kind of voice of reason of Tony, that kind of, especially in the end, try, try to remind him that he's too paranoid, that he's overdoing it, that he should calm down and should do things differently.
And Tony always keeps him around, but he pushes him away. And does not want to listen to him. And the interesting development is that Manny is pursuing all these women, American women. They're all blonde, same as Elvira. So similar as, as Tony, both are kind of similar there that pursuing like a blonde American woman.
But where does Manny then found love and companionship and relationship? It's with a brown-haired woman, and it is with a woman with the same cultural background. She's also from Cuba. It's the sister from Tony. So they form a bond and want to establish something.
And this is basically what is inaccessible to Tony because Manny seems content in most of the scenes and he does not actually do so many things, and he seems to enjoy the things that are happening around him and enjoy himself. So it's a kind of a mirror image of Tony in this regard.
And by seeing Manny fulfilling this and getting this life and getting this family, then come multiple things together. So the frustration about the things that he cannot really achieve, even though that he can achieve everything else, everything in the material world, because his journey is a completely material one.
His journey, not spiritual journey, sees it then manifested in the relationship between Manny and Gina. And Gina, he sees as a kind of part of his innocence. So he tries to provide for her, but at the same time, he does not want to have her intermingled with all the business he does.
So he almost kills a guy because he's dancing with Gina. Even though that she's a grown woman and could do whatever she wants, but he wants to protect her. He wants to have her separated from the drugs, the violence, this lifestyle. And suddenly she comes together with his, uh, best friend and she's very happy about it to see Tony, to have him find out.
But it is not really the thing that Tony wants. And so this is the point that Tony would really have to shift. Like his internal focus and need to do something about his worldview. He's realizing that he's in a dead end, but at the same time, he's not really changing anything. He's just pushing more and more.
And this is why he gets more hysterical during the course of the movie. In the beginning, he's very calm, like in all situations, like people are pointing guns at him, people are threatening him, and he's very cool. He has very low affect, but in the end, he gets hysterical in every situation and is completely over the top. And just throwing around affect like anything.
So he does not make this connection that he needs to change something about himself. And this is why he's doomed, because he needs to make this psychological transformation. He needs to turn inward. He needs to realize that there, the reason why life did not turn out the way he wanted, well, it turned out the way he wanted, but not the way he needed.
The psychological need was never really fulfilled. So he kills that possibility when he kills Manny and destroys the relationship with his sister. And this is what I mean when the character can see it in his face and everything that happens afterward, this complete apathy and just like acceptance. And it's clear for him that he will die because there's no hope for him.
Like he, really made the bed he now has to lay in. So this is a look at his people and the interactions. And Elvira, she's then gone. In the end, she's not there. She just runs away, leaves him alone. So absolutely no connections there. Like everything else loses him also.
And he has a piece of humanity in the sense of that he did not want to kill this journalist and his family that were inside the car. And this then brought him then his downfall because his drug friends from Colombia could not accept that because he was supposed to kill someone because this is what Tony does. He kills people.
And he decided against that and put his morals above that. But he could not do this very last step of accepting Manny. And Gina as a couple and yeah, having their own thing. So the movie of course is about criminality and about criminals.
And we have to keep in mind that these movies are incredibly, incredibly popular. So if you look in popular movies, popular stories, books, It's very often, it's about criminals. And of course, Jung talked about this also.
And first, I will start with a quote from the movie, which is also happening in the restaurant, which is a great scene from front to end. And Tony says, what you looking at? You're all a bunch of fucking assholes. You know why? You don't have the guts to be what you want to be. You need people like me.
You need people like me so you can point your fingers and say, that's the bad guy. So what that make you? Good? You're not good. You just know how to hide, how to lie. Me, I don't have that problem. Me, I always tell the truth, even when I lie. So say goodnight to the bad guy. Come on. The last time you're gonna see a bad guy like this again.
Let me tell you. So people are drawn to that. People are drawn to criminals and to criminal acts. And it is interesting when you take this movie, which has a huge cultural impact and is kind of, uh, on the list of movies that is incredibly popular with men.
And it's even sometimes seen as a kind of red flag when men are interested in these kind of movies. And the movies I'm talking about, like for example, Fight Club and American Psycho and also Scarface. But at the same time, it's saying something about masculine psychology, that there's a deep psychological part in there that speaks to men because it expresses something.
It expresses this like drive and ambition. But also this suffering under that and the consequences that can come from that. But also in the end, we always like to see criminals and especially criminals brought to justice.
So Scarface, the movie, would not be so successful if it would just be Tony being successful and happy in the end as a criminal drug lord. No, we have to see him die. We have to see him suffer in the end because this is a price you pay for breaking the moral code and breaking law and going against the collective.
So Jung sees this as, on the one side, you go against the collective to become an individual, but you have to kind of combine both the individuality and the collective. You cannot just be individual. You cannot only be an artist that does art that nobody understands or be a criminal and go against Everything.
It's not only that society will punish you, but also your own psyche will punish you. But Jung describes this fascination that we have with criminals. A person may contain a devil in the unconscious, for instance, an evil part of his personality. Then in his vicinity, there is someone who is that devil.
And an unconscious person is much relieved when someone else takes over that role. So that he can believe himself to be perfectly nice and decent. This is the reason why we appreciate detective stories and movies that demonstrate crime and bad people like Tony Montana. We love villains. We read the stories of their lives with great interest.
We find the life of Al Capone, say, very fascinating simply because he represents certain contents of our own unconscious. It's interesting that Jung talks about Al Capone. Because Al Capone has as a nickname Scarface. So I guess Jung would be also very interested in the movie Scarface. The original version came out in the '30s. It's unclear whether Jung saw it or not.
But to continue the quote: As long as I am in such a condition that a brother or an aunt or someone else represents the devil to me, I can live peacefully. My unconscious is sufficiently expressed. And this is what Jung often talks about in context of the psyche and the things that have to happen for us psychologically. We have to express those things.
We have, he says, libido, so energy that needs to manifest in the world. And this can be anything, certain actions, certain words. And he says, for the anima, it also needs to be expressed. It needs to go somewhere. It's like an energetic system that needs to unload on the world.
But of course it needs to do so in an integrated manner, integrated with oneself, but also integrated with society. So this is why we love stories and experiencing in our free time. Like we, we seeing this 3-hour journey of a man rising and falling and all the, the, the violence this brings and all the destruction.
Tony is an incredibly destructive person. His mother also realizes this immediately, that there's something wrong and he only will bring bad things. And Gina's too young to know this and realize this, and she's also blinded by this, yeah, possibility in this lifestyle and this materialism.
And what has to happen, it has to be integrated in society and it needs to be integrated within the individual. And if this does not happen, there's something happening with this individual as this energy starts to blow it apart. Jung always talks about this, unless you make the unconscious conscious, it will dictate your life and you will call it fate.
And this is very often what happens in these movies. People are unconscious about the things that they're doing and they cannot repent. So in good movies and happy endings, they can repent, there's redemption. For Tony, there's no redemption. He's too far gone and he has to suffer the consequences. And this is basically death.
And this is then what in Greek theater is called catharsis. This is why people went to the theater to be emotionally purged, to see the psyche being acted out on stage, represented by the actors, to show the interaction between the different parts and how to resolve them and how to integrate them or not to integrate them. Right?
Whether it's a comedy with a good end or tragedy with a bad end. And we always had both from the beginning of our times, and we find great joy in both of those. And this is what Jung talks about when he says, oh, this is the second part of life where people then create culture because they can reflect on these things.
They can also formalize them and represent them and people then find meaning in them, even though that they might not yet understand it, what it all means in the great scheme of things or for themselves, but they already know in their psyche is something is reacting to it. And this is then the fun to find out why something is speaking to one.
Something is speaking to one, and this is already the start of the individual journey that one has through life. So this is what we explore today. And the story of Tony Montana and Scarface. And I hope you had fun and you learned something. And now I'm really curious about the discussion part and your impressions about the movies and thoughts and yeah, everything.
So thank you very much.